today the map wall show the media has
identified the real victims of the
massacre of Christian children by a
trans shooter the real victims of course
are trans people somehow meanwhile
Nashville police are refusing to release
the shooter's Manifesto could there
possibly be any valid reason to withhold
the full truth about this crime from the
public well no absolutely not also the
press secretary for the governor of
Arizona responded to the shooting with a
tweet threatening to kill more quote
unquote transphobes so far nobody has
apologized or been fired for this and
Josh Hawley calls for hate crime
investigation into the shooting even if
we think that the hate crime category
shouldn't exist as a legal category can
we still demand that this be categorized
as one I think we can and I'll talk
about that and much more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
inflation has consequences the recent
surge in gold prices is directly tied to
an extremely volatile Market this is why
gold has historically been a great hedge
against the stock market and against
inflation the only company I trust to
help you diversify into gold is Birch
gold group diversification has never
been more important precious metals will
always have inherent value gold is a
tangible and finite resource
uncontrolled by any single government or
financial institution as such they
cannot simply be printed on a
government's whim like paper currency
can Birch gold can help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into a tax
sheltered Ira in physical precious
metals text Walsh to 989898 to get a
free info kit on gold today with an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews Birch gold
is the company I trust to protect my
future and yours that's Walsh to
989898 today
in many ways the response from Nashville
police to the mass shooting by trans
terrorists at a Christian School here in
town has been admirable that starts of
course with their physical response
their emergency response to the shooting
itself yesterday we saw the the
harrowing body cam footage a group of
officers obviously well-trained highly
skilled
made their way into the building
clearing rooms as they went eventually
confronting the shooter and quickly
dispatching her and neutralizing the
threat now we greatly overused the term
hero these days just like we overuse so
many other terms effectively rendering
the labels meaningless and that's a
shame because it's it's a term that
would actually apply in this case to
those cops they are in every sense
Heroes and then after the shooting they
continued to um the police did continue
to handle the situation with great
transparency and forthrightness the
police chief has been direct and clear
clear with his answers during his press
conferences they released the body cam
footage they released the security
camera footage of the shooting the
shooter entering the building
they've provided a lot of information
but there is one glaring omission and
it's an Omission that becomes all the
more glaring considering how transparent
they've been about everything else
the trans shooter wrote a detailed
Manifesto and we know about that because
cops told us
apparently explaining what she was going
to do what her plans were and why she
was doing it
they have not allowed us to see the
manifesto
a couple of days later we still have not
seen the manifesto and according to
reports yesterday we may never see it
this is from The Daily Caller quote
Nashville police will not be releasing
the manifesto of the deceased Covenant
School shooting suspect a police
spokesperson told the Daily Caller news
foundation on Tuesday Nashville Metro
Police Department announced that they
had found writings from 28 year old
transgender suspect Audrey Hale's home
on Monday that indicated a calculated
and planned attack according to an uh
nmpd press release the police
spokesperson told the dcnf Tuesday that
the department had no intentions of
releasing the documents to the public
anytime soon citing the ongoing
investigation into hail quote no we will
not be released in the manifesto during
an open investigation the spokesperson
said the police spokesperson did not say
for certain whether or not the manifesto
would be released in the future after
the investigation was closed and
restated that due to the ongoing nature
of the situation there was no intention
by law enforcement to release the
documents
well this is just completely
unacceptable and also incoherent they're
investigating a crime committed by a
dead assailant and the person is
thankfully dead that there's no
conceivable reason at least not any
valid conceivable reason why that
investigation would be impeded by
allowing the public to see
these documents
okay and if I can't even imagine what it
would be but if there are a couple of
things in there that for some reason it
would if if we if that was published it
would impede the investigation then you
could talk about redacting certain
elements of it now even redacting the
documents
can be highly problematic
but my point is they're saying we can't
see any of it we can't see even a single
line of it
and that doesn't make any sense
we have a right to know why this
happened
now the why seems rather obvious but we
should also see it laid out in writing
if it was and apparently it was
and we have a right to know what or who
the other targets were supposed to be
we can either
just like with anything else we can
either be left to speculate in the dark
or we can be given the full truth and as
we've seen time and time again the
speculating in the dark option doesn't
help anyone
and we know that because this is the
option that the powers that be uh so
often choose
now when I say it doesn't help anyone
maybe I shouldn't say that because uh
what I mean is that it doesn't help the
public it doesn't serve the best
interests of the community it's not good
for society when vital truths are
withheld from us leaving us to speculate
and assume and come up with theories
but in this case it does serve the
interests of LGBT activist groups who
are actually actively campaigning to
prevent the public from ever seeing the
manifesto Newsweek reports quote calls
for police to release the manifesto that
authorities say was written ahead of
Monday's Nashville Nashville school
shooting has prompted concern among
lgbtq plus groups who caution against
the publication of such a document quote
it should not be published Jordan Budd
the executive director of children of
lesbians and gays everywhere told
Newsweek the focus should be on how this
was able to happen in the first place
there should not be such easy access to
deadly weaponry Charles Moran the
national president of Log Cabin
Republicans a GOP organization that
advocates for equal rights for lgbtq
plus Americans also told Newsweek that
there are serious consequences for the
public release of the manifesto Laura
McGinnis a spokesperson for pflag agreed
telling Newsweek that um publication on
these documents would increase the risk
of contagion she said that while the
manifesto would help a law enforcement
and policymakers identify potential
warning signs to prevent future
tragedies ultimately the contents don't
change the outcome of the tragedy
quote regardless of the shooter's
intentions the real issue here is the
ease of access to deadly weapons in
Tennessee and elsewhere Bud said adding
quote all children no matter who their
parents are or how they identify should
feel safe and supported at school that
includes a world free from gun violence
now you'll notice uh shockingly that
these LGBT groups are mysteriously
silent about these kinds of concerns
after shootings by white supremacists
I mean they're more than happy for those
manifestos to be published and they
always are
but in this case they caution against it
the only mildly surprising thing about
this is that they they haven't really
bothered to come up with a plausible
excuse for this glaring inconsistency
and hypocrisy
instead they essentially confess to the
truth they want the discussion around
the shooting to remain focused on a
politically useful issue like gun
control
don't tell us why this happened they cry
uh you know that'll make it more
difficult for us to use the tragedy for
political gain
most of all they're desperate to protect
their victim narrative
this is their most potent political
weapon and more than that it is the
foundation of their entire ideology
they must protect at all costs the
hallucinatory notion that LGBT people
and in particular trans people are
oppressed and marginalized and you know
they're the ones being targeted not the
other way around
a Manifesto full of anti-christian
ramblings from a trans-terrorist
psychopath would be a powerful counter
example to this idea
so powerful that they can't allow it to
see the light of day
of course even without the manifesto we
still have the simple and terrible fact
that a trans Mass killer slaughtered
children at a Christian school that's
all we need to know or all we should
need to know
yet the left helped helped Along by the
lack of transparency around the
manifesto is still clinging to its
preferred victim narrative
they insist that even though a trans
person murdered Christian children
the real victims are trans people this
seems to be the consensus as you might
expect on Tick Tock watch
so about the tragic school shooting that
happened today at a private Christian
School in Tennessee
um the shooter was born a biological
female and they went by he him on their
LinkedIn so they're they're painting The
Narrative that you know they're trying
to blame transgender people you know the
whole thing but every other school
shooting that's happened in the last I
don't know decade have been white men
and many of them identify as Christians
so let's not go there but I do want to
say that expect more of this kind of
chaos and destruction when you bring
fascism into this country the more you
don't love people the more you shame
people the more you treat people like
they're Untouchable in society what do
you expect people to do of course the
the shadow inside of them is going to be
so angry and retaliate in Revenge that's
what happens when you decide to try to
control people through legislation you
try to harm people through legislation
it's like
the world needs a lot more love not more
hate
no uh first of all all of the School
shooters for the last decade have not
been white men and as for your question
what do uh we expect people to do
what do we expect what do we expect a
trans person to do if she's upset about
not being affirmed or whatever
what do we expect well um
we expect her to not murder children
let's start there
that is a basic standard of behavior
that we hold everyone to it's not even
the bare minimum I mean that is a bar so
low that it's still sitting on the
ground we expect her to refrain from
killing nine-year-olds we expect you
know a lot more from people actually but
yes we do expect to begin with that they
act like human beings and not murderous
demons
this has been the prevailing message on
the left yesterday we uh we talked about
a group of trans activists called the
trans resistance Network who published a
statement claiming that the shooter was
a victim of her own shooting they
lamented that quote life for transgender
people is very difficult and made more
difficult in the preceding months by a
virtual Avalanche of anti-trans
legislation and they reason that she
felt that she she had to commit the
shooting in order to quote be seen
now um
according to these people also the
shooter's problems are compounded by the
fact that she's being posthumously
misgendered along with perhaps the
greater problem that she's burning in
hell but uh but along with that she's
being misgendered here's Tick Tock again
Eden hail that's the name of the
Nashville shooter this video is about to
be very uncomfortable for a lot of us
it's very uncomfortable for me to talk
about but we need to talk about it Aiden
did a very horrendous thing period Point
Blank we need pew pew reform in our
country but the way that the media and
the police are misgendering and dead
naming Aiden is quite concerning it's
also concerning that I had to go to the
telegraph from UK to actually get
Aiden's chosen name It's upsetting that
constantly it is she her pronouns that
is incredibly frustrating because even
though they did this horrible thing does
not mean that we get to to do those
things that's a boundary and we can hold
people accountable without being
transphobic even for some of the most
horrendous things so while you're
watching this also watch for transphobia
because it's very clearly coming out
foreign
just to be clear uh her dead name is
Audrey because she's dead thank God so
really they're both her dead names I
guess yeah she says that uh even though
the
shooter murdered children that doesn't
mean that we get to use grammatically
correct pronouns in reference to her
well actually it does in fact we get to
use grammatically correct pronouns about
people even if they don't commit mass
shootings
the mass shooting gives us permission to
say lots of other things about her that
she was a monstrous bloodthirsty
murdering worthless piece of garbage for
example but as for the pronouns we get
to uh do that regardless
actually listen to this check this out
this is going to shock you
we get to say whatever we want
to or about her or you or anyone else
that's what we get to do
what you don't get to do is control our
words or our minds
I can say whatever I want about anyone
and I will and I can say whatever I want
about any trans person and I will
they do not get to dictate anything to
me that's what they don't get to do
I talk about them according to how I see
them and what I think about them
and according to what is actually true
I don't talk about them according to how
they see themselves I am using the
filter of my own mind
and of reality I am not using the filter
of their minds
that's the way that this works
but the shooter herself isn't the only
trans victim here according to the left
there have been many headlines like this
from ABC quote anti-transgender
sentiment follows Nashville shooting
conservative political figures focused
on the shooter's reported trans identity
and This from NBC fear pervades
Tennessee's trans Community amid focus
on Nashville Shooters gender identity
and here's a bit from that NBC article
says within 10 minutes of police saying
that the suspect was transgender the
hashtag trans-terrorism trended on
Twitter around the same time Republican
lawmakers including Senator J.D Vance
and conservative Firebrand
representative Marjorie Taylor green
insinuated in social media posts that
the shooter's gender identity played a
role in the shooting well no that wasn't
the well they may have insinuated but
actually began with the police chief who
who strongly suggested that
um anyway it says and by Tuesday Morning
the cover of the Rupert Murdoch owned
New York Post Red quote transgender
killer targets Christian School
well yeah because that's what happened
oh so so apparently what we're learning
here is the New York Post had a headline
that's just accurate I mean that's
exactly what happened
quote we're terrified for the lgbtq
community here Kim spoon a trans
activist based in Knoxville Tennessee
said more blood's going to be shed and
it's not going to be shed in a school
Denise Sadler a drag performer who's
transgender said that she had already
hired four armed guards before uh Monday
shooting to secure a drag show that
she's hosting at a gay bar in Nashville
this weekend she with uh Big Air quotes
around that by the way following the
anti-trans rhetoric spawned by the
shooting Sadler said quote unquote she
is not planning to hire eight
you don't know if the shooter's gender
identity is going to trigger a community
of people who already hated us to come
and try to shoot us to prove a point
Sadler said at the end of the day
there's a lot of hurt going on there's a
lot of anger going on there's a lot of
confusion going on aislin Bailey the
acting president of Tri-Cities
transgender it translates important
advocacy group based in Johnson City
Tennessee said that her quote unquote
her initial reaction to news the suspect
was transgender Was Fear
I knew that as soon as anyone mentioned
that it was immediately going to become
the center Focus instead of what should
be the focus and that's gun violence in
this country Bailey said
well that really sums it up doesn't it
that sums it up six innocent people were
massacred and the first thought the
first thought
the first thing that he thought about uh
the first thing this transactus thought
about was how this would affect him
his very first thought was concerned for
himself
after hearing that three children and
three School staff members were murdered
forget about the fact that the fears
make no sense okay trans terrorism
should be a cause of concern for those
of us who oppose the trans movement not
for Trans people themselves
and even aside from that the narcissism
is once again the point
always points back to that this is a
movement of self-worship and
self-obsession a movement full of people
who cannot see beyond themselves people
who cannot see the rest of the world do
not acknowledge the existence really of
other human beings
because they're constantly staring in
the mirror even if it is oftentimes more
of a fun house mirror
constantly staring back into their own
egos obsessed with their own emotions
and their own need for affirmation
that is what we learn here
known as a lesson that we've already
learned many times
now let's get to our five headlines
with the current rate of inflation
prices of essential goods are not going
to be going down anytime soon it's more
important now than ever to start looking
at ways to cut costs you've heard me
talk countless times about supporting
companies that support your same values
which is uh which is why I switched to
Pure Talk Pure Talk is the best
anti-wilt company that uses the same
Nationwide networks as major carriers so
you'll get the same reliable coverage
that you're used to without any of the
wokeness added on top of it with a range
of affordable plans to choose from you
can find the perfect option for your
needs get unlimited talk text and plenty
of data for just thirty dollars a month
switch over to Pure Talk at as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number they're us-based
customer service team makes the switch
really easy Pure Talk is so short you're
going to love your service they're
backing up with 100 money back guarantee
you can go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save 50 off on your first
month that's puretalk.com probably code
Walsh puretalk is simply smarter
Wireless
Senator Josh Hawley is demanding that
the shooting be investigated as a hate
crime and he talked about that yesterday
to a reporter let's listen to that
this is a hate crime against Christians
this was targeted at a Christian School
it was targeted at Christian children it
was targeted Christian Educators because
of their religious affiliation that's
what police has said this wasn't random
it wasn't just like she chose the shoot
or some random school you know she chose
this school because it was a Christian
School the police even said yesterday
that she had issues with her own I think
she'd been to the school had been a
student formula she had issues with the
school itself and presumably the
religious Doctrine so all of this is
going to come out this way we need an
investigation and this needs to be
treated for what it is is a hate crime
and listen we're seeing this across the
country we're seeing this hateful
rhetoric directed at people of faith
based on their religious beliefs all
over we're seeing this in Missouri we're
seeing this around the country we need
to be clear about this you can say
whatever you want but you cannot incite
violence and we need to be clear that
this kind of hateful rhetoric that leads
to violence has got to be condemned
federal law explicitly prohibits the
targeting of Americans based on the
religious affiliation based on their of
religious practice or belief it's in
federal law it's a hate crime what
police have told us in Nashville is that
this was targeted that this was targeted
at this Christian School the Christian
students the Christian employees and
that they believe it was definitely
premeditated and there was a deliberate
attempt to Target the school that looks
like a hate crime to me we should find
out exactly what went into planning this
we should find out what the influences
were on the shooter you know who
influenced this person what what sort of
hateful rhetoric contributed to this and
we we need to find out the extent of
exactly what happened but above all we
need to be clear that when you target
people of faith that is a hate crime I
hope the White House will condemn this I
hope that everybody will come out and
say this was a hate crime we have to
condemn it
uh well he's obviously correct about
this I mean completely correct but
um
the the problem always with this uh
subject is what makes it difficult is
because the hate crime category
shouldn't exist
and I'm pretty sure that I don't want to
speak for him I'm pretty sure that Josh
Holly would agree with that I might be
wrong
um but at least for me what I would say
is that the the hate crime category
shouldn't exist
and I've explained many times why that's
the case it's just it's a it's in a lot
of ways incoherent it's intentionally
vague
um it's uh it is intended to be
subjective
um so that the powers that be can decide
what qualifies and it also just it it
assumes the ability first of all to to
be able to discern you know whether
someone was experiencing hate when they
committed a crime which which in many
cases is impossible because you can't
see inside someone's Soul
um
and even if it is clear that there was
hate and it's pretty clear in this case
that there was plenty of hate involved
um it also assumes that hate is like the
the worst possible motive for a crime
and that those who are motivated for
hatred you know by hatred that is a that
is a a motivation that is
um
that is worse than any other motive for
the for that reason we have to treat it
in this kind of special way I don't
think that's true either
you know I think people who are
motivated by hatred and are motivated to
violence
are obviously capable of doing horrific
things as we saw this week here and um
if they are captured rather than being
killed on the spot they should face the
ultimate punishment for it
but there are other things that can also
motivate people to commit crimes that
are just as heinous
you can be motivated by in plain
indifference uh just your your inner
emptiness as a human being and I think
there's probably a lot of that going on
here as well
um
you can be motivated by materialism and
greed you know if it's going in we look
at any of these videos that
unfortunately are circulating on social
media all the time of someone robbing a
gas station and just murdering the gas
the the the guy behind the cash register
for no reason
yeah
what's the motive there
did he did he hate the guy standing
behind the cash register probably not
but he wanted the money so there's greed
and he's indifferent to his human life
so there's indifference
if he had killed the guy because he
didn't like color of his skin or because
he didn't like a sexual orientation
would that make it worse
no I'd say it makes it just as evil and
so it should be treated the same so
that's what makes the hate crime
category that's why it shouldn't exist
but it does it does exist and because it
does exist because it exists as a as a
legal concept
um it must be applied equally and so we
have to insist on that and that puts us
in the in the awkward position of having
to say well this category doesn't exist
but since it does
um you you know this must also fall into
that category
because if we're going to have this
category then um
all of the problems with having it only
become worse
when it is unequally applied which it is
and the fact that it's so unequally
applied again is one of the reasons why
it shouldn't exist to begin with
but because it does yes this uh it we we
even if we are
ultimately shouting at a brick wall or
nothing's going to happen we must still
insist that it be applied equally and
according to the letter of the law
you know this obviously qualifies based
on what we already know even without
seeing the manifesto we've already been
told this was a target attack against a
Christian School trans person you know
everything we need to know
to at a minimum begin to investigate
this as a hate crime
uh
it's from the daily wire Arizona
governor Katie hobbs's spokeswoman was
blasted online after she tweeted an
image Monday suggesting that transphobes
quote unquote
should be gunned down after an hour
after hours after a woman who identified
as transgender killed six people
including three on children inside a
national Christian School the gift taken
from the 1980 film Gloria tweeted by
Jocelyn Berry who's uh hobbs's press
secretary show the actress Gina Rollins
wielding two pistols and was captioned
us when we see transphobes it was posted
Monday even as the nation mourned the
murders of three nine-year-old children
and three adults
um
this was
yeah this was this was the same day as
the shooting so here this is uh the
press secretary for the governor of
Arizona so not some obscure official is
the press secretary spokeswoman
um tweeting hours after the shooting
it's on the same day but it's hours
later
so she obviously knew about it okay it
wasn't like this was tweeted and um it
would have been an inappropriate tweet
regardless
but it wasn't like this was tweeted 15
minutes after refer reports first
surfaced of the shooting and so then
there'd be plausible deniability maybe
she hadn't heard about it yet in this
case this is hours later it had been the
top trending topic on Twitter she's on
Twitter she knows that it happened
clearly and um she decides to tweet an
image of a person holding a gun
with the message us when we see
transphobes
now
we imagine the equivalent right imagine
that there is a
shooting at a gay club and the press
secretary for a republican governor
let's say the the press secretary for uh
Glenn Younkin in Virginia let's just say
tweets out an image the same day that
says you know of the same image someone
holding a gun and then the message is us
when we see homosexuals
okay if that were to happen and it never
would
that would happen it would be first of
all the lead story on every news
broadcast
that would probably be protests in the
street and that person most importantly
would be fired and denounced within
minutes
it it wouldn't even take 15 minutes and
they would be done their career is over
they're not getting any other job in
politics or probably anywhere else uh
they'd be denounced by everybody and
that would be it for them
only in this case
the Tweet remained up for hours it was
finally taken down
hours later actually remained up for
over a day so over 24 hours later it is
um I'm not even sure if it was taken
down in fact instead the press secretary
put her account on private so she locked
down her account so we don't even we're
not sure if it was deleted or not
but she locked down her account and as
it stands right now there's been nothing
said about it
the media has mostly ignored it of
course and uh as it stands right now the
latest from what I checked No statement
no nothing uh the governor of Arizona
Katie Hobbs has not addressed it it's
not said anything about it hasn't
announced it this person hasn't been
fired there hasn't been any apology
so what they're hoping they can do is
just lock down the account pretend this
isn't happening and move on from it
now
it's as always not enough to Simply
point out the double standards
okay we can point them out
but then the next step has to be forcing
them to comply by the same standard
they're not going to do it on their own
okay that's not something they're just
going to decide to do in the interests
of fairness
they're not going to say to themselves
well you know uh
if this was happening on the other side
this is how we would react so let's be
consistent let's have integrity and be
consistent here they're not ever going
to say because they don't have integrity
and the the double standard is part of
the point here the hypocrisy is is the
point
so they're not going to choose on their
own to rectify this or hold themselves
to the same standard which means that we
have to do it we have to insist upon it
we have to demand it
um
and it might take some effort
okay
like this is in in the interests
of holding them to their own standards
of getting rid of rather than just
complaining about this double standard
of actually getting rid of it
that means that when something like this
happens we have to be persistent
which means we don't just like send some
tweets and it trends for 15 minutes and
we say oh look at the double standards
this is outrageous and then we move on
if we do that then nothing changes
we have to be persistent about this
we basically we have to put
Katie Hobbs in a position where she has
to decide do you really want to go
to war over this I mean is this is this
something you really to use their
expression they often use and throw it
out so you really want to die on this
hill is that actually what you want
now we we can't actually force her to do
the right thing and fire this person
we can't force her to do it
so if she actually wanted to like plant
her flag on the hill and say absolutely
not I'm I'm not gonna you know I'm
standing by my press secretary who
tweeted this violent threat after
children were just killed
if that's what she's going to do then
fine but then we should force her to do
that what we can't allow them to do is
just ignore it
um
so that starts by and we could just
start with this I'll I'll give you the
number to the governor's office in fact
I'll give you the mailing address
um and the number and then on the
website there's the the uh the fax
number if you if anyone still sends
faxes if you have a fax machine then
I'll give you that number too so the
mailing address is state capital 1700
West Washington Phoenix Arizona 85007
um and then
uh the phone number is
602-542-4331-602-542-4331
and if you are listening to this through
some time warp from the year 1995 and
you have a fax machine 602 542-7601
so to begin with
um
we should be flooding the governor's
office with phone calls demanding that
this person is fired because that is
what we're demanding not an apology now
apology two
but then also fired nothing less than
terminating her employment will be
acceptable
because that's what happened to anybody
on the other side and we're going to
insist on it in this case this person
needs to be fired their their job and
livelihood must be taken away from them
that's what needs to happen and we're
going to insist on it
um
though we should also mention I say this
is about holding them to their own
standards and not having a double
standard
by any standard also she should be fired
for this even if the left even if they
weren't a bunch you have cancel happy
you know people that were constantly
trying to cancel people for the things
of the day you should still be fired for
this
there's no standard where this would be
appropriate
all right
uh
another article from the daily wires is
a nine-year-old girl who was one of the
three um
school children gunned down by the
national shooter inside a Christian
School was desperately trying to stop
the massacre by pulling on a fire alarm
when she was murdered
and there as I mentioned yesterday there
have been many stories and reports of
heroism inside the school
um
and uh including one of the teachers
that was that was killed was apparently
running towards the shooter trying to
protect her children
um and in this case it was Evelyn who
was running to pull the fire alarm to
protect her her classmates and her
school
incredible bravery
um
also infuriating because that little
girl should not have been in a situation
where she was called on to be heroic
um which is why we need armed security
in all the schools
it's uh it's incredible to hear about
the stories of teachers that are rushing
at you to unarmed teachers rushing at
Shooters small children that are acting
to try to to try to protect their
classmates
these are heroic
Acts
but they shouldn't be in a position
where they have to do that okay the
teacher shouldn't be in a position who
that are who are unarmed should be in a
position having to throw themselves at
armed assailants
which is why again there needs to be
there need to be guns in the school guns
that are carried by the good guys
armed security armed teachers we need
all of that
and that's you know
if that's not just apparent to by now to
everyone then then I I don't know at
what point does it become clear
and of course on the left they go the
other direction here's Randy Weingarten
calling for the repeal of the Second
Amendment in response to this
an epidemic that our great nation must
solve
and how many lives
will be shattered
before we have the courage to do what
Scotland did what Australia did what New
Zealand did what other great democracies
do
we must solve this epidemic
and that's up to us
yeah that's uh that is directly calling
for the appeal the Second Amendment and
uh and a kind of unilateral disarmament
and it's not going to happen
um
and you think especially now
they they the way it works in their
Twisted heads is after an event like
this they think this is the perfect time
to make this argument people are going
to be even more receptive to the
propaganda because they're afraid of
quote-unquote gun violence and so people
are going to be even more willing to uh
lay down their arms and get rid of their
guns but of course for rational normal
people it's exactly the opposite okay we
are not
because we're Americans and we have
rights and the Second Amendment does
exist and it's not going to be repealed
um
we're not receptive to the idea of
disarming in general
but we are the least receptive of all
right after an event like this
because this only highlights yet again
why we need to be armed
it's a it's just a it's a very simple
equation
evil exists in the world evil people
exist in the world
and if we ever encounter them we we
don't want them to have the upper hand
that's it that's all
um
as from Fox News says reparations
Advocate Robin ruse Simmons told CNN
that she does not know how San Francisco
will pay uh the black residents five
million dollars each in reparations
after successfully awarding reparations
to approved residents in Evanston uh
Illinois CNN's Adrian Brodus asked
Simmons during an interview about how
the city of San Francisco will pay black
residents five million dollars
Simmons says I don't know and so those
are the challenges that we all have as
municipalities I don't know
so this is the policy uh that we're
advocating for well how are you actually
going to do it though well I don't know
that's the challenge the challenge is I
have no idea how to do it I well yeah I
guess I would agree that's a challenge
as a former older woman turned activist
Simmons push reparations in Evanston
which became the first city to award
such restitution to Black residents who
qualify those who qualified were awarded
grants up to twenty five thousand
dollars for a down payment on a new home
home renovations or mortgage assistance
however the Evanston city council voted
to approve a cash option on Monday
the approval of recreational marijuana
which went into effect 2021 funded
evanston's reparations
Simmons told the outlet it's one thing
to identify a harm and prescribed remedy
in the case of Evanston we have been led
to understand and appreciate that home
rule taxes are our most viable way to
fund reparations
being that they're within our purview
uh Ramona Burton who's one of the 14 who
received reparations Grant Evanston told
Brodus that she used the money for
Windows her roof and the chimney on her
home
San Francisco's reparations committee
proposed paying each black resident
Community 5 million dollars and the
Board of Supervisors is considering the
proposal
so
using the example from a town where they
decided 25 000 they're now saying well
you know why not five million dollars
and why not 5 million I mean why not why
not award uh why not award 50 million
each
especially if the little details like
how does that even happen how do you do
that uh if if that's uh you know if
these are minor concerns these are just
minor logistical concerns then yeah why
not 50 million dollars
and forget about you know the other
questions of like how how has always
comes up when this when this insane idea
of reparations
is uh is presented
how do you determine
exactly who gets it and who pays
well I know how they do it
you know if they if if you qualify as
Black by by their determinations then uh
that automatically makes you uh a you
know someone who suffers from the
historical trauma of slavery and so you
get the reparations payments
and if they decide that your white and
you know whoever qualifies as white that
can kind of change depending on what
they need in the moments but if they
decide that you're white then that means
that you are uh you are somehow you have
inherited the guilt which means that you
have to pay up
never mind the fact that
you know there are many many black
people in this country who their
families came here long after slavery
was abolished
there's many many white families in this
country whose families came here long
after slavery was abolished and in fact
they came here and their families and
their ancestors were uh were targets of
discrimination and Prejudice as well
never mind all that
also never mind the fact that even if
uh you can trace your lineage all the
way back to slavery days
that is not in itself an argument for
being able to cash in
on suffering that you did not experience
and depression that you did not
experience
in fact that you that you missed by uh a
century more than a century
so none of that makes any sense can't
explain any of it but let's do it anyway
sounds like a great idea let's get to
the comment section
[Applause]
who's the blame
it's a sweet baby gang
have you tried an innumerable amount of
skin care products claiming to reduce
the appearance of wrinkles lightened
dark under eye circles and restore a
more youthful appearance no doubt you've
been disappointed spring is here and our
friends at genucel have the solution for
you the one that you've been looking for
just as I have all these years until I
found genucel so for the first time ever
genucel is including both the ultra
retinol and Dark Spot Corrector in their
most popular package at genucel.com
Walsh genyourself Ultra retinol contains
a powerful retinol alternative that is
safe for your skin they're Dark Spot
Corrector will help reduce sunspots plus
you'll still get genucel's world-class
under eye bags therapy to help alleviate
puffiness gen yourself promises
immediate effects you'll see results in
12 hours guaranteed or your money back
my Show's audio engineer Josh has a
total baby face and the way that he
keeps his skin okay
okay we're just looking as everyone
everyone on the crew everyone involved
in the show they all use uh Jen USA and
we love talking about it we're always uh
talking and gabbing about uh about
genyourself and the way that he keeps
his skin looking as fresh as newly
driven snow is with genucel's wide range
of products he constantly tells me how
much he loves it while hooking up my mic
it's really weird so don't wait visit
genucel.com Walsh to save over 70 off
their most popular package every order
subscription includes a luxury gift box
with two free Springtime Essentials just
in time for warmer weather you can go to
genusal.com Welsh
Endor BR says no way the Legacy Media
will still be talking about the story by
next week regardless of any further info
that comes out well yeah are you kidding
they'd prefer to move on from it
now I mean they want to move on from the
15 minutes after it happened well 50
minutes after they found out who
perpetrated the shooting they wanted to
move on from it and um
and they will if we let them
so this kind of goes back to the Katie
Hobbs discussion
um if we if we allow everyone to move on
and uh and we decide that this is going
to be yet another thing that happens and
matters a lot to people for 25 minutes
and then they forget it ever happened
like if we decide that if we go along
with that then then that's what will
happen which is why we can't allow that
uh Bob says there is in fact a rational
argument for not having armed security
despite the extraordinary media
attention school shootings are still
rare armed security is expensive schools
are still one of the safest places for
children to be much safer than their
homes
yeah I'm not sure about what measure
you're saying that the children are
safer in their homes
and um
and also
it depends on the home right
so I know okay my my children are not
like just subject to statistics
so I'm not going to look at is when you
talk about the the dangers in the home I
assume you're talking about dangers of
abuse and that sort of thing
well when I look at my own children okay
and if you're just if you're if you're
to take all the children and then all
the abuse that happens then come up with
some kind of percentage so a child is uh
whatever percent likely to experience
abuse at home but when I look at my own
children I don't say well there that
percent likely to experience abuse and
no they're zero percent likely
because that doesn't happen in my home
so my children are
safe in my home
you know are are completely safe in my
home aside from you know the
possibilities of accidents and tripping
and that sort of thing that can happen
but uh my my children are safe from home
I know that
now it's different though you send them
off to school
and now the statistics do come more into
play
um
and
now yes is it is it true that uh that
school shootings are still rare yes
but they happen
and they happen with a with a certain
frequency we know that
it's not like when I went to school
okay when I went to school it was uh you
know a column I was I was in I think I
was in Middle School when Columbine
happened
and it was like it was this unheard of
earth-shattering thing
and now it's a couple times a year
something like this happens
so they do happen they happen with with
uh you know on on a reoccurring basis
there is a real risk there and that's
reason enough to have security
if anything like uh how oft how common
are bank robberies
it's not like uh every Bank in the
country is getting robbed every day bank
robberies are quote unquote rare
and in fact even if you got rid of all
armed security at all banks
they would still be relatively rare
because most people aren't going to rob
a bank even if the opportunity presents
itself
and yet obviously you have security at a
bank
no matter how rare it is
I mean you you could go if we went
through a period of like
five years where no banks were robbed at
all
I would still say yeah you should have
security at the bank
why because there's a lot of money there
and uh and it's worth protecting it'll
be very Intel it would be very stupid to
not protect all the money and cash you
have there make yourself a soft target
when you've got all that money is a bad
idea
well the schools have our children
okay quite a bit more valuable in fact
infinitely valuable our children
and it's worth protecting
and that goes for you know that goes for
almost any other institution almost any
other building where we are accustomed
to seeing armed security
and we'd be kind of disturbed if we
didn't see it
in any of those cases
that the chance of an attack of a
violent attack is is you know
relatively small
and yet you have the security anyway
because the risk is still there
so how do you decide whether there's
security I think it's you take two
things into account is there a risk of
something like this happening
okay is there like a quantifiable risk
that it could happen
and
is the uh you know whatever this
whatever the security is protecting
is that valuable enough to justify the
expense
and when it comes to money in a bank I
would say yes and when it comes to our
children in school I would say a million
times more yes
so that that's the argument as far as
I'm concerned
um
let's see Rick Wilson says it's going to
be awesome when Matt moves over to mug
club and is no longer bound by big Tech
rules and Jeremy boring's capitulations
to the left I want Matt Unleashed you
want me what what leash do you think I'm
on exactly like what what am I of all
the things that I say every single day
on this show what am I not saying like
what do you think I'm not saying
uh believe me I I whatever comes to my
mind I simply just say you know if I if
I if if I believe that it's something
that needs to be said I will just say it
and uh and that's it
Jeff says what do you make of the
reports about a child sex abuse scandal
at covenant there are rumors that the
shooter may have been a victim seeking
Revenge so yeah I um
I have seen this and I'm only
acknowledging it because I've seen this
circulating on social media uh people
that are you know doing the detective
thing the detective work and so the The
Narrative that some people are passing
around on social media is that there was
a child sex abuse scandal at this school
years ago and uh so maybe the shooter
was a victim and was looking for Revenge
because of that now there's no evidence
at all that the shooter was a victim no
evidence of that it's just a it's
speculation and this speculation has
um
has become rather widespread on social
media anyway
now what do I make of it I think I think
it's just that I think it's
I think it's total speculation no
evidence at all and I think it's
completely implausible as well I think
it's completely implausible that this
was the mo the motive for the crime
because she wasn't you know usually with
Revenge you're going after the person
who did a terrible thing to you
she went and killed children
so her revenge for
being abused as a child was to kill
children
she didn't kill anyone who would have
been responsible for doing this
and that's usually what revenge is
and also there's the fact that um which
is not taken into account by the people
that are engaging in this uh speculation
there's also the fact that the police
have told us that she had other Targets
in mind she had other Targets in mind
and she settled on this Target because
it didn't have security because it was a
soft target
we were told that directly she was going
to go somewhere else and didn't because
it had security so she went here
so that alone I think debunks this this
whole Theory
so what we know is that it was targeted
at this school but also there were there
were other targets that she would have
gone to
so what does that tell us
it tells us that that there's something
about this kind of school that she was
going after but it may not have been
this exact school that you get so in
other words she wanted a Christian
School
and there might have been other
Christian schools that she would have
targeted but she decided not to and she
went with this one
that's what that tells me
you know I'll never understand virtue
signaling making yourself look important
with the least amount of effort it's
it's like the reputation equivalent of
Stolen Vowel Valor and reputation is
just one of the things that Jordan
Peterson discusses with his Roundtable
group of Scholars and theologians in the
latest episode of Exodus check this out
I do I don't think when we've talked in
our culture a lot about virtue signaling
it's not exactly a great phrase because
really what you're trying to do when you
virtue signal is you're trying to
acquire reputation that you haven't
earned and the reason that people are so
motivated to do that is because once you
can abstract an ethic there's actually
nothing that's more valuable than your
reputation right it's the thing upon
which all the trades that you uh in
engage in with everyone else depends
right you're as good as your reputation
and so if you can get that falsely it's
a real crime and if you can Savage it
without cause it's an equally egregious
crime and that's why it's much worse do
it so often and so narcissists and I'm
sure that's much worse so Jordan to to
have an an ill-gotten reputation that's
bad but to take away someone's actually
earned reputation I know that there are
no certain sense too it's a battle
between two Devils two sizes well new
episodes are coming uh online every week
exclusive for daily wire Plus members
join now at dailywire.com subscribe to
watch Exodus now let's get to our daily
cancellation thank you
today we cancel a woman named Laura Jade
who identifies herself in her Twitter
bio as a freelance journalist she has
apparently been paid I assume she was
paid anyway it's a right for
Publications like New York Magazine and
rolling stone if you're wondering what
sort of stories she chases down what
kind of journalistic Investigations she
conducts well um here's her latest
expose okay she she poured through years
of my tweets and other posts uh going
back to 2012.
to find out how I responded to previous
mass shootings and to compare those
responses to what I've said about the
Covenant School shooting
and the results are shocking or shocking
to her anyway apparently so she thinks
she she thinks she's got me here she
thinks she she has something something
big it's just not clear what exactly
that is so let's go through this thread
together Laura writes quote good morning
let's compare Matt Walsh's reaction to
the National Covenant School shooting
with other shootings that involve the
murder of very young children
she provides some screenshots of my
tweets over the past few days it's all
right in line with what you've heard me
say on the show I talk about how you
know I have nine-year-old children
myself I can't imagine the pain of
losing them I say that we should always
remember what happened at Covenant
School I talk about the danger posed by
trans extremists
um and all of that all that you've heard
me cover now she moves to the Past
cool Uvalde Texas 524 2022 19 elementary
school children two teachers dead only a
soulless piece of would politicize
the shooting of elementary school
children perpetrators should burn in
hell armed security is the answer here
she's summarizing accurately what I
tweeted in response to that shooting she
continues Parkland Florida 214-18 17
dead most between 14 and 18. Walsh do
not politicize this don't make this
about mental illness have you read this
great speech LOL Valentine's Day Walsh
posted the Valentine's Day tweets after
he retweeted a news item on the shooting
so here she summarizes again less
accurately in the screenshots you see
that I I sent a tweet calling for armed
security in schools I make the point
that a government building that houses
our children should be protected just
like we protect almost any other
government building I also talk about
the problem of human evil you know how
this come this comes down not not merely
to Mental Illness but or policy failure
but to evil
uh she screenshots this tweet of mine
evil is everywhere this is me now evil
is everywhere around us and within us it
may make us feel safer to pretend it's a
political issue or a policy issue but we
are fooling ourselves
and then there's a tweet about of mine
about fatherlessness and how that
contributes to violence as well
continue to next part of Laura's thread
she writes quote twelve-year-old Tamir
Rice's murder at the hands of a
policeman in 2014 wasn't a school
shooting but he was only three years old
older than the nine-year-olds who died
in Tennessee let's see what Matt Walsh
had to say about that what's that
nothing just tweets about BLM writ large
cool Walsh didn't have a Twitter account
in 2012 when Adam Lanza killed 26 people
at Sandy Hook Elementary School but
here's some of the stuff that he wrote
on his blog and she here provides a
screenshot of a blog post that I wrote
where I talk about the futility of gun
control
she ends her thread with this at no
point during my combing through Matt
Walsh's disgusting Twitter feed this
morning have I found a single expression
of howling grief at the genuine horror
of children dead at the barrel of a gun
at least not until a trans person killed
them
now Laura's Twitter followers have
championed her investigative work on
this issue celebrating this as a damning
report that exposes my rank hypocrisy
and fraudulence here's just a few here
are a few reactions from leftists
responding to or sharing this threat
this is what they're saying
uh quote an incredibly obvious
conclusion can be made here and that's
that people have agendas this is a
Smoking Gun for Matt Walsh and all the
conservatives acting like they really
care about the issue at hand another
says thread of proof that Matt Walsh is
a bigoted Nazi loving monster who cares
about nothing but pushing his own
fear-mongering trite
I think I mean tripe uh another one a
thread which more than proves that Matt
Walsh is a hypocritical Craven blood
sucker who explodes exploits tragedies
for his own self-satisfaction and need
for clout
another one says this should disqualify
Matt Walsh in every argument he attempts
to make
another one this threat is an incredible
breakdown of how inconsistent a
far-right extremist like Matt Walsh is
when discussing the horrifying loss of
children's lives during due to shootings
especially when he feels he can exploit
it for his own transphobic Crusade
now meanwhile people with IQs somewhere
above refrigerator temperatures are left
confused I mean where exactly is the
disqualifying hypocrisy where is the
incredible inconsistency they think
they've found
because what she's really discovered
here is that I've been saying the same
things about these tragedies making the
same kinds of points hammering the same
themes over and over again for years she
has exposed not my inconsistency but my
consistency she has gone through my
closet in search of skeletons and
discovered instead 50 versions of the
same flannel shirt basically which is
actually what you would find in my real
closet and it's supposed to make me look
dishonest for reasons that remain quite
mysterious
I'm not even feigning ignorance here for
comedic effect I honestly don't know
exactly where she or the left is sharing
this thread imagine the hypocrisy is
she says that I only express grief over
the murder of the children at Covenant
School but not over any of these other
shootings yet you can see my expressions
of grief about those other shootings in
the very tweets that she screenshots
also since we're going back to 2012 to
read my obscure blog which uh I was
writing as a no-name small Market radio
host here's what I posted on the day
that the Sandy Hook massacre happened
and and Laura conveniently forgot to
mention this you went all the way back
to see what I wrote about Sandy Hook
basketball turns out and I don't even
remember writing this I wrote something
on the day that it happened a direct
response to it and here's what I said
this is a day when I hate my job I don't
want to go on the air and talk about 26
people being killed in elementary school
I don't want to talk about 18 children
being slaughtered by a cowardly satanic
piece of worthless filth I have no
commentary to offer on this I have
nothing but anger and confusion and I
have prayers I pray not only for the
families of the children who have been
stolen from the world but I pray for all
of us I pray that God will heal this
nation because we are deeply spiritually
broken evil is very present Among Us
don't ask if we can have if we have
enough laws or enough medication or too
many guns or too many video games ask
why there is so much evil in this
country that's the question I don't have
the answer but I know God is the
solution so that's what I wrote at the
time that's me expressing grief that's
me pointing to the problem of evil and
spiritual Decay that's me saying that
the solution cannot be found through
policy changes or psychiatric medication
that's me saying exactly what I always
say about these things that's me saying
everything that I said on this show
yesterday about the Covenant School
shooting
over a decade later and saying the same
things
presumably Lara would claim that the
real hypocrisy is in the fact that uh
you know
um I'm decrying the politicism
politicization of school shootings in
the past and yet have called called out
the violence of radical trans activists
in response to this latest shooting
and it's true you know I I do oppose the
politicization of school shootings while
also opposing the rampant hate and
violence in the gender ideology movement
I hold both of those views and they are
not in conflict with one another
as I outlined yesterday in great detail
trans activists regularly call for
violence they regularly engage in
intimidation emotional blackmail
harassment threats Etc they feel
entitled to act out this way and they
are implicitly and sometimes explicitly
given permission to do so and I think
that is a bad thing
I think that this will will and does
result in chaos and bloodshed because
it's designed to
okay that's not my
political view
it's not something I'm saying to score
political points which is what it means
to politicize something
I'm saying it because it's the cold
reality of the situation the gender
ideology movement is once again the most
hateful and violent movement in America
and it's not even close
if this is a political statement well
that's only because one political party
the Democrat Party has decided to attach
itself to this movement and act as its
mouthpiece and enforcement mechanism
that's not my fault
I didn't tell Democrats to sell their
souls to the gender cult
they did that on their own
so yes I am opposed to trans terrorist
slaughtering children
I am opposed to politicians using mass
shootings to score political points I am
opposed to trying to solve the problem
of human evil with gun control policies
I don't think it can be sufficiently
addressed with psychiatric medication
which I think very often can do more
harm than good
I believe that we're a state you know in
a state of cultural rot and decay
I believe that there's an emptiness and
hopelessness at the core of so many
people in our society and this is what
fundamentally drives them to commit
these heinous acts of evil I think the
collapse of the nuclear family is a huge
part of this equation
I think we need a spiritual Revival in
this country I think all of these things
have always thought them have always
said them will continue saying them
which may make me boring and it may make
me predictable
certainly doesn't make me a hypocrite
though
but it does make you Lara today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block you
can become a member today and use code
wall should check out for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]